bon je me dois de vous prévenir
l'histoire d'aujourd'hui c'est pas la
plus gay la plus féeriques la plus
goûteuse vagues ce qu'on a raconté sur
cette chaîne mais elle n'en est pas
moins intéressante vous savez j'adore
les histoires y compris les histoires un
peu plus blocs genre les documentaires
sur les serial killers les faits divers
tous ces trucs là j'adore et mon péché
mignon dans ces trucs là c'est les
crimes non résolus et souvent fait dans
les trucs non résolus généralement temps
c'est autant que la police ait pour
autant tu as des théories rien n'est
avéré fin je trouve que ces genres un
foutoir à spéculation les affaires de
crimes non résolus on met plein
d'indicés d'éléments dans la tête comme
ça et on dit et voilà on n'en sait pas
plus on sait pas ce qui s'est passé vers
la sphère la plus connue de ce genre en
france c'est celle du petit grégory qui
a eu lieu je crois dans les années 80
dans les vosges et un documentaire sur
celle ci sur netflix je vous conseille
fortement ça illustre parfaitement tout
ce que je vais vous dire au sujet de ses
affaires non résolues mais celle
d'aujourd'hui c'est pas celle du petit
grégory la sphère dont on va parler
aujourd'hui c'est celle de blair adams
c'est un canadien de 31 ans qui semble
du jour au lendemain avoir perdu la
raison et avoir pris la fuite sans qu'on
sache pourquoi par contre qu'on sait
c'est que quelques jours plus tard on
l'a retrouvé mort à moitié nue sur un
parking à des milliers de kilomètres de
chez lui
alors on n'a pas un milliard d'infos sur
l'histoire de sa vie on sait juste que
les années qui ont précédé le jour de sa
mort il était contremaître sur des
chantiers et qui l'adoré son taf qui
s'entendait très bien avec ses collègues
pas vraiment quelqu'un de normal qu'à
une vie normale cependant il a eu
pendant une petite période de sa vie une
bonne addiction à l'alcool et la réussit
à y mettre fin en rejoignant groupe
d'alcooliques anonymes auxquels il a été
présent tous les jours pendant deux ans
on est en 1996 et le comportement de
blair change radicalement et dort
presque plus il est tout le temps sur
ses gardes il a des sautes d'humeur
hyperfréquences bref ses proches le
reconnaissent plus alors évidemment face
à ce changement de comportement sa
famille s'inquiète elle le questionne à
lui dit et ce qui est quelque chose qui
va pas est ce que tu aimerais nous
parler de quelque chose malheureusement
à damerey ce super vague et il leur dit
juste écouté je devrais pas vous en
parler et encore un jour on sait pas de
quoi il s'agit
on est le 5 juillet 1996 et blair va
dans une banque à vancouver retirer
l'intégralité de ses économies il met
tout ça dans une sacoche noire et il se
casse sans dire un mot
deux jours plus tard don blair retourne
à vancouver pour cette fois prendre un
ferry dans but de rejoindre les états
unis il espère en réalité atteindre
seattle et il a prévenu absolument
personne de son départ il arrive au port
il se prépare à embarquer sauf que les
douaniers le trouve hyper chelou alors
ils le prennent à paris le questionne et
lui demande pourquoi ils seront à
seattle il lui demande pourquoi il a des
bijoux ou des lingots d'or et du cash
dans sa sacoche et malheureusement les
réponses de blair n'arrive pas à les
combattre il ya plein d'incohérences ya
plein de trucs bizarres et donc les
douaniers lui dise bon c'est simple tu
n'iras pas aux etats unis aujourd'hui
rentre chez toi il retourne donc assurer
sa ville natale où il rend visite à sa
mère et à des amis et évidemment ils
l'oublient de leur dire que ça fait deux
jours qui transporte tout sa tune dans
une sacoche et qui vient aussi de se
faire recaler par la douane en tentant
de rejoindre les états unis mais malgré
tout il a toujours l'air très mal
désorienter les gens autour de lui le
voit et à cela s'ajoute un autre élément
le fait qu' il ne va plus au travail
depuis plusieurs jours personne ne
comprend ce qui se passe avec blair mais
ce que tout le monde comprend c'est
qu'il ya bel et bien un truc qui cloche
chez lui en ce moment alors
naturellement son entourage suspecte
qu'il est en fait une maladie mentale et
donc lui suggère d'aller voir un docteur
de prendre sans lui de se faire aider en
fait mais vous vous en doutez blair
refus malgré tout à force d'être
questionné tout le temps partout les
gens de son entourage qui comprennent
pas ce qui se passe il lâche quand même
quelques petites informations par
exemple il confie à sa mère que des gens
propagent des rumeurs sur lui bon on
n'est pas super avancée mais c'est mieux
que rien quand on lui parle de son
travail blair se met à pleurer ce qui
veut dire que visiblement dans sa tête
il n'a pas eu le choix de démissionner
dernier élément très celle où il veut
plus du tout être dans son appartement
assuré donc carrément il va dormir chez
sa mère ce qui est typiquement ce que
quelqu'un frais s'ils se sentaient
menacés s'il se sentait traquée et ça se
confirme quand il va avouer à un ami à
lui que son comportement étrange
viendrait du fait qu'il est poursuivi
par quelqu'un qui veut le tuer
rien que ça
ce jour-là blair rassemble toutes ses
affaires et quitte la maison de sa mère
et c'est malheureusement la dernière
fois qu elle le verra vivant il veut
partir très loin et très vite du coup il
va à l'aéroport de vancouver et l'achète
un billet d'avion direction frankfort en
allemagne pourquoi franck forte parce
qu'il ya vécu l'année d'avant en 1995
pour aider son beau-père sur des
chantiers il a aussi son ex petit ami
qui est là bas ce qui veut dire qu'il a
un contact sur place une personne qui
peut potentiellement l'aider sauf que
blair annuler tous deux heures seulement
après avoir acheté les billets ils se
les faire rembourser on apprendra par la
suite que sa copine allemande attendais
absolument pas sa visite et on saura
jamais pourquoi il a annulé aussi vite
son voyage et qui il devait rejoindre
sur place peut-être que comme le vol
était prévu au lendemain blair s'est dit
c'est morges reste pas une journée de
plus au canada c'est trop dangereux donc
j'annule le vol et je fais autre chose
il va donc en pleine nuit toquer chez
une amie pour lui demander de l'emmener
en voiture jusqu'à la frontière avec les
états unis malheureusement son ami
refuse et lui dit écoute fréhaut il est
minuit passé je sais pas à quoi tu joues
mais vient on voit ça demain blair
s'excuse et il repart sans lui en dire
plus
le lendemain très tôt dans la matinée
alors qu'il fait encore nuit blair et
c'est traverser la frontière américaine
à pied c'est à dire que les frontières
c'est des lignes de voitures mais c'est
jamais un mec qui s'est tapé le chemin
jusqu'ici à pied et qui compte se taper
le chemin de l'autre côté jusqu'à la
ville la plus proche à pied forcément
les douaniers se pose des questions et
nouvelle fois il se fait interroger une
nouvelle fois c'est un échec une
nouvelle fois il reste au canada il
retourne une nouvelle fois à l'aéroport
de vancouver cette fois non pas pour
acheter des billets d'avion n'est pour
louer une voiture une nissan avec
laquelle les retourne poste des
frontières duquel il vient de se faire
virer sauf que cette fois ça passe il
est enfin aux états unis déjà une fois
aux états unis le premier truc qui fait
c'est rouler tout droit jusqu'à
l'aéroport de seattle pour acheter un
billet d'avion pour washington et cette
fois il va vraiment prendre l'avion il
va pas se faire rembourser leurs prêts
en revanche un truc qui fait tiquer les
autorités c'est que ce jour là quand il
achète son billet d'avion il prend un
aller simple pour washington et c'est
aller simple qui coûte 800 dollars coûte
en fait deux fois plus cher que s'il
avait pris un aller retour c'est
peut-être un détail pour nous mais pas
pour les enquêteurs qui eux comprennent
qu'en fait au moment ils achètent le
billet d'avion il est encore extrêmement
stressé au point où l'argent n'a aucun
intérêt pour lui il fait aucune
optimisation il s'en fout il veut juste
se barrer le plus loin possible le plus
vite possible et ce peu importe le prix
la nuit passe et blard atterri à
washington aux alentours de 6 heures du
matin il loue une nouvelle fois une
voiture cette fois une toyota et il se
met à conduire plein sud sans jamais
s'arrêter à 17h30 on retrouve sa trace
puisqu'il a aperçu dans une station
essence à knoxville dans le tennessee
dans cette station essence il fait plein
de sa toyota ip l'employé en cash mais
mauvaise surprise quand il revient pour
démarrer sa voiture elle démarre pas
l'employé de la station service appelle
donc un dépanneur pour venir en aide à
blair un certain gérad sap vient donc à
sa rescousse ils lui demandent les clés
et déjà ils voient que sur les clés il
ya un logo nissan oui vous avez fait
lien la nissan c'est la voiture que
blair conduisait à seattle là c'est une
toyota qui conduit ça veut dire qu'il
est tellement stressée carrément qu'ils
se trompent de clés gérald le dépanneur
le prends bien ça me fait plutôt marrer
ça arrive d erreur d'étourderie et donc
ils demandent à blair de fouiller ses
poches à la recherche de la bonne clé
celle de la toyota sauf que il refuse
oui c'est bizarre mais vous avez bien
entendu blair refuse catégoriquement de
fouiller dans ses poches face à ça
gérald préfère ne pas se prendre la tête
et il remarque la caisse il proposa
blair de le déposer à l'hôtel le plus
proche le faire fields in un hôtel
d'affaires en périphérie de knoxville
blair rentrer dans l'hôtel mais au lieu
d'aller réserver sa chambre il va faire
plein de va et vient entre l'accueil et
l'extérieur
[Musique]
et finit enfin par s'adresser à la
réception et a réservé une chambre qui
va payer en cash avec un billet de 100
dollars il récupère la carte d'accès à
sa chambre mais il part tellement vite
que la réceptionniste a même pas le
temps de lui rendre sa monnaie l'hôtel
va régulièrement appelé sa chambre pour
lui dire de se rendre à la réception
pour récupérer sa monnaie mais blair ne
décrochera jamais tout simplement parce
qu'il n'est jamais allé dans sa chambre
à 19h30 on le voit quitter l'hôtel sur
les caméras de surveillance et c'est la
toute dernière trace qu'on aura de lui
il est 7 heures du matin et une équipe
d'ouvriers se rassemblent au 74 71
crosswood boulevard ils travaillent sur
le chantier d'un hôtel en construction
situé juste en face du fairfield inn
l'hôtel où devait dormir blair et
boivent un café ils commencent à sortir
du matériel et évolue loin quelqu'un
allongé par terre dormir sur le parking
ils vont à sa rencontre pour lui
demander partir mais se rendre compte
que ces liens squatteurs ni un sans abri
c'est un cadavre la police est contactée
et les officiers qui arrivent sur place
commencent à sécuriser la scène de crime
il fouille dans les poches du cadavre et
découvrent rapidement son identité c'est
blair adams à défaut de pouvoir vous
dire ce qui s'est passé on ne sait
toujours pas à l'heure actuelle je peux
vous dire tout ce qu'ils ont trouvé sur
cette scène de crime déjà le corps est
en piteux état c'est à dire qu'on
aperçoit énormément de blessures dont
une grosse entaille au front vu le choc
c'est probablement un coup de barre de
fer ou un coup de pied de biche qui a
causé une blessure pareille les
policiers découvrent également des
lésions sur les mains de blair qui sont
des blessures typique de quelqu'un qui a
voulu se défendre d'une agression blair
aurait donc reçu plusieurs coups
violents infligées par un mystérieux
assassin en revanche qui l'a tué c'est
non pas à ce coup au front c'est un
coups qu'il aurait reçus dans l'estomac
et corps était tellement fort que
l'estomac se serait rompu provoquant une
hémorragie un choc septique les
blessures sont impressionnantes mais la
scène de crime restent mystérieuses
blesle retrouvée à moitié nue avec son
jeans descendu jusqu'aux chevilles il a
plu ses chaussures aux pieds ses
chaussettes elles sont retournées de
l'intérieur est posé à côté de son corps
et chose d'autant plus bizarre c'est que
les policiers vous retrouver
l'équivalent de 4000 $ en devise
allemande canadienne et américaine
éparpillés tout autour de son corps ils
vont aussi retrouvé sa fameuse sacoche
toujours rempli des bijoux et des
lingots d'or qu'il ya mis quelques jours
plus tôt c'est ça le truc le plus
bizarre c'est que la ou les personnes
qui l'ont tué n'en avais absolument pas
après son argent ils n'ont rien pris
entre le fait que toutes ces affaires
soient éparpillés comme ça autour de lui
et le fait qu'il soit à moitié à poil 11
monde si en fait ses agresseurs ne
cherchez pas quelque chose qu'il cachait
sur lui en plus de ça d'après les
autorités il présenterait aussi les
signes d'une agression physique sexuelle
ses ravisseurs seraient donc peut-être
aller jusqu'à chercher à l'intérieur de
blair bref la moindre des choses qu'on
puisse dire c'est que c'est très bizarre
malgré tout on a plein d'éléments donc
on se dit que la police a de quoi faire
sauf que pas du tout la police galère
ils ont beau chercher dans les moindres
recoins du parking il n'y a aucun indice
qui mène à une piste viable aucune arme
aucune trace laissée par le ou les
tueurs et pire encore aucun témoin
direct la police réussit quand même à
obtenir un témoignage celui d'un gardien
de nuit qui faisaient des rondes dans le
quartier et qui aurait entendu un cri
strident d'une femme à 3h30 du matin
malheureusement ça n'aurait pas alarmer
plus que ça ils seraient pas allés
investiguer une bonne excuse pour dire
qu'il appelle le courage d'aller voir ce
qui se passe mais dans la main de blair
les enquêteurs retrouvent ce qui peut
être la réponse à toutes leurs questions
un cheveu un long cheveu qu'il envoie
immédiatement aux labos et bingo ce
n'est pas un cheveu de blair il ya donc
de très grandes chances que ce soit un
cheveux appartenant l'agresseur de blair
malheureusement il n'y a aucune
correspondance avec tous les adn
présente dans la base de données des
policiers ni en 1996 au moment où l
enquête commence ni encore aujourd'hui
pendant le top 6 on retrouve dans
l'estomac de l'ère de la nourriture pas
encore décomposer ce qui veut dire qu'il
a mangé récemment avant sa mort donc
juste après avoir quitté l'hôtel et ça
tombe bien car ça colle avec le récit de
deux femmes qui pensent avoir aperçu
blair dîner avec un homme non identifié
dans un restaurant proche de l'hôtel un
portrait robot est dressé mais la police
n'a jamais été en mesure d'identifier
l'homme du portrait robot évidemment il
est aussi interrogé le staff du
restaurant en question mais rien de trop
beau bref on voit que les policiers ont
quelques pistes mais qu'à chaque fois
elle ne mène à rien et au bout d'un
moment ils arrivent carrément à court de
piste encore aujourd'hui les shérifs de
knoxville disent que c'est la sphère la
plus mystérieuse qui n'ait jamais eu à
traiter on sait toujours pas pourquoi
blair a fui le canada ni ce qu'il a fuie
ni pourquoi il est venu à knoxville on
sait rien non plus sur qui a pu tuer
encore moins pourquoi bref on sait rien
tout court avec le temps la faire tomber
un peu dans l'oubli normal mais là
quelques émissions télé qui vont y
consacrer un ou deux épisodes ce qui va
relancer un peu l'intérêt autour de ce
meurtre et potentiellement apporter de
nouveaux témoignages et justement ça va
permettre de révéler un peu les
comportements étranges des parents de
blaye des années après le meurtre la
mère de blair retourne voir la police
pour leur dire que finalement elle
savait pourquoi son fils s'est rendu aux
états unis pourquoi il l'a pas dit avant
bas tout le monde se pose la question
d'après elle c'est pour se rendre aux
jeux olympiques d'atlanta
il ya zéro blague quoi qu'il en soit
même si c'est vrai ça nous avance pas
trop et surtout ça colle pas trop avec
le comportement très étrange de blair
les jours qui ont précédé sa mort ok tu
veux aller aux jeux olympiques mais
pourquoi tu retires toutes les économies
pourquoi tu essaies traverser une
frontière quasi dans l'illégalité
pourquoi tu annules des billets d'avion
tu viens d'acheter pour en prendre
d'autres bref c'est beaucoup d'efforts
pour un truc plutôt basique et surtout
pourquoi tu achètes pas directement un
vol direct pour atlanta et c'était réglé
l'histoire bref ça fait beaucoup de
questions beaucoup de questions qui vont
intéresser tout un tas de journalistes
qui vont essayer de rentrer en contact
avec la maman de blair ils n'arrêtent
pas d'appeler chez elle pour essayer
d'avoir des infos sauf qu'à force c'est
carrément le père de blair qui répond il
leur fait comprendre que lui et sa femme
ne veulent plus jamais entendre parler
de cette affaire et on peut se mettre à
leur place ça doit être horrible de
reparler tout ça de reparler de la
disparition et du meurtre de son fils
c'est normal mais d'un autre côté ils
ont l'air quand même vachement sur la
défensive 2010 il ya du nouveau une
équipe spécialisée dans l'école cas ici
s'empare de la faire l'écho le cas ici
au delà d'être un mot que je prononce
très mal en anglais c'est toutes les
vieilles affaires non résolues sur
lesquels on fait bosser des nouveaux
policiers qui peuvent apporter un regard
neuf ou des nouvelles technologies qui
permettent de faire avancer les enquêtes
alors tout le monde reprend un peu
espoir ça donne rien il trouve aucune
nouvelle piste ils sont face à un mur et
la police pense que cette affaire
n'avancera plus jamais à moins que
quelqu'un se décide à parler maintenant
que vous savez tout on peut passer aux
théories et oui c'est tout ce qui nous
reste à faire sur ces affaires c'est
spéculer et avoir des théories en
attendant de nouvelles preuves et vu que
ça me rend dingue qu'on n'est pas le fin
mot de l'histoire je vais vous donner
quelques unes des théories les plus
connus comme ça je me sentirai un peu
moins seul premièrement on pense tout de
suite à l'hypothèse que blair était bel
et bien poursuivie par quelqu'un qui lui
voulait du mal blair emprunte de
l'argent à quelqu'un il est dette il
n'arrive pas à le rembourser donc il se
fait éliminer mais vous savez ça
correspond pas avec ce qu'on a trouvé
autour du corps de blair à savoir
beaucoup d'argent autre théorie et si
c'était pas un règlement de compte mais
que c'était tout simplement un contrat
d'élimination parce que blair aurait des
infos compromettantes sur un cartel ou
une entreprise alors ce genre de contrat
ça donne généralement lieu à des
meurtres plutôt clean entre guillemets
c'est à dire il ya mille preuves autour
de la scène de crime et surtout la
plupart du temps on retrouve pas les
victimes et si c'était un gros mafieux
nous on ne saurait pas mais la police
l'aurait su d'une manière ou d'une autre
nouvelle hypothèse blair n'était en fait
poursuivies par personne il avait
peut-être bel et bien une maladie
mentale jamais diagnostic et qui s'est
manifesté il était en pleine crise
paranoïaque il avait vraiment peur
d'être tués mais alors du coup pourquoi
ils se seraient fait tuer et ben ce
serait une coïncidence le hasard fait
qui s'est retrouvé au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment mais dans ce cas quand
même pourquoi blair était à moitié à
poil avec toutes ces affaires
éparpillées autour de lui et ses
chaussettes retourner c'est bizarre
c'est la thèse la plus probable selon
les policiers mais il ya une dernière
thèse que moi j'aime bien il ya pas mal
de gens qui pensent qu'en fait ce serait
peut-être liées à la prostitution ce qui
expliquerait pourquoi on l'a retrouvée à
moitié nue cette théorie du coup dit que
peut-être qu'il aurait vu une prostituée
et qu'il l'aurait agressée alors est
donc appelée à l'aide donc un schéma qui
serait venu la défendent et auraient
défoncé blair à chaque fois ya des
éléments dans chaque théorie qui sont en
contradiction avec l'intérêt en question
ou qui font douter et c'est horrible
bref je le sais vous êtes très frustré
de ne pas avoir le fin mot de l'histoire
comme moi je suis content je suis plus
le seul achat sur quoi qu'il en soit
j'espère que la sphère avancera ne
serait ce que pour la famille de blair
qui est restée sans réponse je vous
laisse là dessus je vous laisse débattre
entre vous voilà il ya là je sais que ça
à partir en débatte vous agressez lui
doit plusieurs sachets 99 % de nos
théories sont fumeuses vu que nous ne
sommes pas policier mais quel kiff quand
même de square enquêteurs pendant deux
minutes là je vais mater un petit
documentaire je vous cache pas je vous
laisse bisous tout le monde
[Musique]
m